allow me to briefly look at the book
which at this point is becoming more and
more Visionary that you've written I
guess over five years ago life 3.0
so
first of all 3.0 what's 1.0 what's 2.0
was 3.0 and how's that Vision sort of
evolve the vision in the book evolved to
today life 1.0 is really dumb like
bacteria and that it can't actually
learn anything at all during the
lifetime the learning this comes from
this genetic
process from one generation to the next
Life 2.0 Is Us and other animals which
have brains which can learn during their
lifetime a great deal right so
and um you know you were born without
being able to speak English and at some
point you decided hey I want to upgrade
my software let's install an English
speaking module
so you did
and the life 3.0 does not exist yet can
cannot replace not only its software the
way we can but also it's Hardware
and um that's where we're heading
towards at high speed we're already
maybe 2.1 because we can you know put in
a
an artificial knee uh pacemaker
etc etc and if newer link and other
companies succeed won't be life 2.2 Etc
but uh well the Company's trying to
build AGI are trying to make is of
course full 3.0 and you can put that
intelligence into something that also
has no
biological basis whatsoever so let's
constrain some more capabilities just
like the leap from 1.0 to 2.0 there is
nevertheless you speaking so harshly
about bacteria so disrespectfully about
bacteria there is still the same kind of
magic there
that permeates Life 2.0 and uh and 3.0
it seems like maybe the thing that's
truly powerful
about life intelligence and
Consciousness was already there in 1.0
is it possible
I think we should be humble and not be
so quick
make everything binary and say either
it's there or it's not clearly there's a
there's a great spectrum and there is
even controversy by whether some
unicellular or organisms like amoebas
can maybe learn a little bit
you know after all so apologies if I
offended anything yeah yeah it wasn't by
that it was more that I wanted to talk
up how cool it is to actually have a
brain yeah where you can learn
dramatically within your lifetime
typical human and and the higher up you
get from 1.0 to 2.0 to 3.0 the more you
become the captain of your own destiny
of your own ship the master of your own
destiny and the less you become a slave
to whatever Evolution gave you right
by upgrading our software which can be
so different from previous generations
and even from our parents
much more so than even a bacterium you
know no offense to them
and if you can also swap out your
Hardware take any physical form you want
of course it's really the sky's the
limit
yeah so the
it accelerates the rate at which you can
perform the competition computation that
determines your destiny yeah and I think
it's it's worth
commenting a bit on what you means in
this context also if you swap things out
a lot right now
this is controversial but my
current
understanding is that that you know
life is best thought of um not as a bag
of meat or even a bag of
Elementary particles but rather it is in
as um
a system which can process information
and retain its own complexity
even though nature is always trying to
mess it up so
it's all about information processing
and
that makes it a lot like something like
a wave in the ocean which is not it's
it's water molecules right the water
molecules bob up and down but the wave
moves forward it's an information
pattern in the same way Euless
you're not the same atoms as during the
first time you did with me you've
swapped out most of them but still you
yeah and
the the information pattern is still
there and um
if you if you could swap out your arms
and
whatever and you can still have this
kind of continuity it becomes much more
sophisticated sort of way before and
time where the information lives on I I
lost both of my parents uh since since
our last podcast and and it actually
gives me a lot of Solace that
this way of thinking about them they
haven't entirely died because
a lot of mommy and daddy's um
sorry I'm getting a little emotional
here but a lot of their values
and ideas and even jokes and so on they
haven't gone away right some of them
live on I can carry on some of them and
they also live on a lot of other and a
lot of other people so in this sense
even with Life 2.0 we can to some extent
already transcend
our physical bodies and our death and
particularly if you can share your own
information your own ideas with many
others like you do in your podcast
then
you know that's the closest immortality
we can get with our biobodies you carry
a little bit of them in you in some
sense yeah
uh do you miss them you miss your mom
and dad of course of course what did you
learn about life from them if it can
take a bit
of a tangent
oh so many things
um
for starters my my Fascination for Math
and
um the physical mysteries of our
University thinking you got a lot of
that from my dad but I think my
obsession for really big questions and
Consciousness and so on that actually
came mostly for my mom
and
when I got from both of them which is
very core part of really who I am I
think is
is um
this um
just feeling comfortable with
not buying into what everybody else is
saying
just doing what I think is right
they both
very much just you know did their own
thing and sometimes they got Flack for
it and it did it anyway
that's why you've always been an
inspiration to me that you're at the top
of your field and you still
is still willing to uh
to tackle the big questions in your own
way you're one of the one of the people
that represents
MIT best to me you've always been an
inspiration in that so it's good to hear
that you got that from your mom and dad
yeah you're too kind but but yeah I mean
the real the good reason to do science
is because you're really curious you
want to figure out the truth
if you think
this is how it is and everyone else says
no no that's and it's that way
you know
you sticked with what you think is true
and and
even if
everybody else keeps thinking it's
there's a certain
um
I always root for the underdog when I
watch movies and my my dad once I I one
time for example when I wrote one of my
craziest papers ever or math talking
about our universe ultimately being
mathematical which we're not going to
get into today I got this email from a
quite famous Professor saying this is
not only but it's gonna ruin
your career you should stop doing this
kind of stuff I sent it to my dad do you
know what he said what do you say he
replied with a quote from Dante segil to
Corso
follow your own path and let the people
talk
go Dad yeah this is the kind of thing
yeah he's dead but that that attitude is
not
how did losing them as a man as a human
being change you
how did it expand your thinking about
the world how did it uh expand you
thinking about
you know this thing we're talking about
which is humans creating another living
sentient perhaps uh being
I think it um
mainly do two things
one of them just going through all their
stuff after they had passed away and so
on just drove home to me how important
it is to ask ourselves
why are we doing the things we do
because it's inevitable that you look at
some things they spent an enormous time
on and you asked in hindsight would they
really have spent so much time on this
so if would they have done something
that was more meaningful
um
so I've been looking more in my life now
and asking you know why am I doing what
I'm doing and I I feel
it should either be something I really
enjoy doing or it should be something
that I find really really meaningful
because it helps
Humanity
and
if it's in none of those two categories
maybe I should spend less time on it you
know the other thing is dealing with
depth up and personal like this it's
actually made me less afraid
of
um
even less afraid of other people telling
me that I'm an idiot you know which
happens regularly and just live my life
do my thing you know
um and um
it's made a little bit easier for me to
focus on what I what I feel is really
important what about fear of your own
death
has it made it more real that this is
that this is something that happens
yeah it's made it extremely real and I'm
next next in line in our family now
right me and my brother younger brother
but um
they both handled it with such dignity
it was that was a true inspiration also
they never complained about things and
you know when you're old and your body
starts falling apart it's more and more
to complain about they looked at what
could they still do that was meaningful
and they focused on that rather than
wasting time
like
talking about or even thinking much
about things they were disappointed in
I think anyone can make themselves
depressed if they start their morning by
making a list of grievances
whereas if you start your day when the
little meditation and just the things
you're grateful for you you basically
choose to be a happy person
because you only have a finite number of
days you should spend them Make It Count
being grateful yeah